what's up donation today where you are
doing logotherapy in a case you're new
to this series we invite a designer to
pick a logo and in this case it's smart
demon coming back I mean I probably
screwed that up again and he's gonna be
redesigning the Bentley logo which this
is gonna be really interesting because
I'm a little nervous for him I have to
be honest with you and in case you're
just tuning in we take logos that you
love to hate and we go and redesign it
and our returning champion March demon
here yes you guys you guys gonna go
check them out it's at at Mart Lyman and
here's some of his work this is what
we're gonna be tackling this is a
classic beloved car brand so whenever we
redesign something like this I'm a
little nervous for our logo therapist
mark why did you pick this one to
redesign what's going on
well to be honest I came across this
very randomly and I didn't actually he
was like okay just it's very bad I was
just struggling to find a number they
wanted to redesign for this for this
episode and all of a sudden I came
across this and I was like I can give
this a try it's not something I've
probably ever owned myself because the
cars are very expensive but still I
could give it to give it a try and see
if I can make me give it my own
great my own version make it a bit more
minimal a bit more modern I guess mm-hmm
I'll try to keep the original look
intact so that was my goal of this to
judge myself mm-hmm this standard was
set really high with the last logo that
you took on with razor a lot of people
tuned in for that they've watched that
they loved it so I guess without further
ado listen let's just jump into it yeah
I'm sure you can I believe enlist some
background information about the
bendiest brands I think I think it's a
carbon almost everyone knows they're
very famous for creating very very
luxurious cars and when I came across
the logo I noticed that the logo looked
a bit like almost like clipart but you
would see on Shutterstock for example
when you type in wings factor or
something like this I think for such a
luxurious company it almost looks a bit
I don't know a bit
cheap like the other like you have like
effector image of waste and you do you
use live trace for example don't be like
that's that's what's obvious harsh this
was created like a cheesy code so I
guess back then they didn't have like
the tools we have right now so that's
why I thought that maybe with the tools
we have today make a creative bit more
for it modern version I guess so and
it's the symbols obviously based on now
on two ways which stands for the freedom
that writing amendment gives you so I
wanted to keep that very intact I want
to keep like the original shape intact
so that people that recognize the logo
will still be able to recognize the new
logo as well and just a summary of what
I'd like about don't like I like the
overall shape of the wings like a nice
be the typography I think is pretty
pretty clean pretty good and what I want
what I think I wanted to improve was the
question of the wings the letter B looks
at bids out of proportion and the wings
look a bit like clipart so I know it's a
bit harsh but that's the the first
couple of sections and I think it'll
look and be a bit more luxurious so
here's some of the sketches I will go
first I'm going to show the sketching
process like last time as well like time
lapse video this is a big setup here
yeah this is what most people like the
previously as well so I'm just keeping
the same the same process every night
every time because that's what the
people like most yeah give the people
what they want
yeah so here we go well it was yeah I
had some bugs with my tablet so a couple
of lines but here's what the way starts
so I'm just redrawing the look from a
memory
see what of what parts of the logo do
remember don't remember so also what
also can leave out this is something
that I do pretty much every time I could
recreate a logo just see how much I can
remember of a logo and my goal was to
create something that's a bit more
simple bit more clean and I guess a bit
more a bit more modern
so in this one you're you're working
with what's there you're not radically
changing it because we want to keep some
of the heritage you just want to have it
a more custom feels that the vibe not so
much more custom I think just more
modern and ok with like with Brad like
Bentley I mean this Brenda that's really
built their their image over the years
and this has came like a really good
reputation
rabbits repetition and also for example
if you buy a Bentley card and that's a
Bentley logo on its it immediate
immediate s3 value so I didn't want to
change too much right so the bread
itself might lose the value of the off
the logo you know mm-hmm so I guess this
is more like my take on it and it's a
bit more modern a bit cleaner and I
think more timeless but that's just my
opinion and I mean people can pick and I
can agree with the people can another
career with this about it yes they can
agree to disagree at some point yeah so
I want to ask you a question about what
you're drawing here are you going into
this with some premeditated plan are you
just doing what feels like a pretty
clear image in my head which I wanted to
do so it's not like a computer from
scratch I already had like a vision for
what I wanted which direction I wanted
to take mm-hmm and then I just started
sketching and trying out different ideas
to different variations of the same
shape because I would have to keep the
shape that's almost the same must in the
previous logo just clean it up a bit so
I'm just trying are variations in the
wings and feathers below so it's
basically yeah just me cleaning up the
original logo and giving it my own
direction I guess hmm it's neat also
that each time you try a new idea you
just duplicate it and keep working on it
right yeah yeah I like it also see that
I like two basic ideas so one is the
wings with the wings horizontally and
one is this one where the geese are
starting at one point and then going
outwards mm-hmm the reason I'm keeping
backups of every ideas because in the
end you might end up combining some
ideas or
going back to one that you created like
it starts because you never know what's
the best idea before you try them out so
okay now this far into these sketching
process here how much time is expired
look in I think the total figure of this
is most about six hours and it's cropped
in to 20 minutes okay so we're at 3
minutes now I'm a really good at maths
but I think I've spent about one hour
here or so okay
good unless yeah do you feel sometimes
like when you're when you're kind of
exhausted or you feel like you've run
out ideas do you just take a break and
come back yeah I mean it's impossible to
just work constantly behind the computer
means sometimes sitting behind a
computer gonna be the next costing so
I'd like to go for a walk I'd like to go
get some coffee or what I also really
like doing is when I'm working on like
four or five project at the same time
when I don't have ideas for one certain
project this go work another project and
all of a sudden ideas are popping into
my head for the project I haven't been
working on so I think it's also good to
go outside and just refresh a bit and
you don't want to force things you know
when you're sitting on your computer and
you don't have any ideas on the project
just don't try to force you just go
outside and get some fresh air and
mm-hmm
this will come by itself Americo I wanna
take this moment to say thank you to Adi
body for supporting the channel thank
you very much we appreciate that really
interesting to see in your process and I
like wings a lot of like I've tried
drawing wings and it's it's harder than
you think to get the proportions right
yeah so the the variation working on the
moment I didn't end abuse and because I
don't know if I'm allowed to say this on
the stream but it felt a bit like the
Second World War you know my Nazi wings
the eagle yeah it does yes I'm not going
my that's a bit a bit less that's right
yeah
I like this version another on the
bottom rides which really yeah very
minimal yeah now we've seen this trend
happen in logo designs that a lot of big
brands have gone very simple and minimal
and in some in most cases I agree with
the decision to go that direction but in
some cases I really miss the nostalgic
feeling the the history that's baked
into some of these more ornate logos
like the the one the classic example for
me is Burberry I do like the original
Burberry logo but it has its limitations
and I also like the modern treatment in
which they're doing today but I do miss
it a little bit I think my final result
for this case for like for the bentley
mulsanne logo i think it's might sound a
bit arrogant but cookie but i think it's
the best of both worlds it looks both
modern was still classical that makes
sense Chris what was it about the
Burberry logo that made it feel more
like nostalgic let me pull it up our
hallmark sketching here so I can speak
to it not from memory and while you're
sketching a lot of people are asking hey
could we get a video and just Mart's
sketching what it was your hand maybe
they just don't want to see my face I
don't know I think maybe they want more
detail they want to and you know
understand every little bit that goes
into every stroke every brush the pigs
yeah this is pretty pretty much so maybe
next time a bit slower so it could
actually a you just slow it down next
time we have more time now that we're
doing one logo therapist at a time oh my
life next time like do I go ok we'll do
our 8 hour livestream right I think it
can create something in an hour
really yeah I think so ok that sounds
like a good challenge then everybody
coming out with the super chats nice
okay so the Burberry why do I like the
original Burberry logo it was a night
charging on an armored horse and it was
galloping midst
and leaping forward with the guy holding
a lance with a banner and it felt very
British to me and I'm I'm in love with
like heraldry these family crests and
when I was growing up I didn't know what
they were but I I remember going to the
store and looking for a clothing that
had these emblems some of the Ivy League
schools had them and I didn't know that
I was called heraldry at that time and I
just that was kind of like my first love
and design along with skateboarding and
comics but so that's why I have a
personal connection to it
so when we look at the new Burberry logo
it's a clean sans-serif typeface it's
bold it's and I would I would wear that
on a shirt I would have that on a
package for sure I'm just telling you
that I miss the old one a little bit
yeah all right I hope that answer that
question you know Mart the original
Bentley logo is on a slight elliptical
it's not perfect circle right and I
noticed in your sketching you're kind of
maintaining that oblong thank you did
you at one point contemplate just make
in a circle I haven't thought about that
okay all right I mean this was like
pretty obvious choice we did these want
to keep that because I think it also
helps to recognize the new logo but I
guess if I like for example if this was
like extra client project and of course
would spend more than just six seven
hours on it so that would be an option
it up then would explore but in this
case because of the limited time I
didn't explore it but yeah I get what
you're saying and like an extra client
project and I would be like okay this is
the the option with keeping the same
proportions and this would be an option
with using new proportions right you're
saying with less time constraints you
would explore more and just see what
works the best yeah for example yeah
like a true professional okay also
people popping up in the in the chat
here appreciated Damian I know that
you've been watching a lot of our
content I see you commenting all the
time so thank you very much for
supporting us Damian I'm not gonna try
to pronounce the last name I probably
gonna butcher it and also really quickly
with tricks media thank you so much
really appreciate you
now I'm seeing that you're going more
this is kind of like what I would
consider more of a traditional wing
drawing
yeah there's feathers and there's
tapering and I'm kind of liking this
maybe I'm just a sucker for nostalgia
yes that's basically a mix of both
worlds and mine mm-hmm this is also the
reason that like I just said I didn't
want to have like the Third Reich this
direction to keep it a bit more
nostalgic yes I think we have to be
aware of these connotations that people
are naturally going to draw
unfortunately fortunately if if I got
this right you guys correct me in in the
chat if I if I screw this part up is
that Hitler's propaganda minister the
designers they did a really good job of
combing history the history of designed
for really interesting symbols the the
swastika was originally a I think a
Japanese symbol representing infinity
and they just flipped it around going
the other direction a very powerful
symbol and they appropriated and the
Eagle that with the wing spread was
really a symbol if you if you look into
this I think Romans used it it is very
similar drawing so they just went back
into history and pulled something out
said let's use this that's updated so
unfortunately some of these symbols have
been tainted by the rather nefarious
things that the the Third Reich this
Nazi Germany party was doing medley is a
British car I don't think they want to
be associated without at all Churchill
will be calling or rolling over in his
grave right now yes
okay so somebody's telling me the
original symbol was Indian and not
Japanese thanks for that clarification
our audience is so smart this is me
pandering but they are so smart
yeah it seems like you're getting
somewhere because you're getting tighter
and tighter with your drawings are you
starting to feel like this is the
direction yeah so this was the
discussion unlike most of the ones that
are created and so this is always like
one final step for me where I refine the
expression Photoshop before I go into
illustrator because I want to make sure
that the proportions are used in
Photoshop we're also going to come out
correct once I go into illustrator
because I really hate having this cut I
like and then all some and it'll stay
there having to change things because
they don't work right that's why I
refined in my box you can work fast this
way you can try different ideas and you
go illustrator as your final step to
really tighten up the vector drawing but
you don't want to make those decisions
there right yeah so for some people work
for clients and I will usually for
example if they want three proposals I
will send them to refine sketches and
then once they pick a sketch if you like
then I will create effect the first for
them yeah so I think most designers will
usually send them the vector logos of
three proposals but since my sketches
are often already very clean the clients
able to envision of how they find a lot
of a look like yeah I got a question for
you some of these grid lines that you're
pulling up the one with the lines
converging just out of curiosity where
do I come from
so as my sketch saw always already
pretty clean I'm just using proportions
that make sense to me so for example the
the same around the B that's for sample
said it's the the width is 1 X the the
space between the lines there is for
example 1/2 X so I'm just eyeballing it
but at the same time I'm using
that makes sense in the finally saga
that makes sense it's just to confirm
your drawing with a tablet is a Wacom
yes yeah welcome if you're listening we
need a sponsor
yeah a new one yeah it's like eight
years old still good we're saying but we
need the new quasi yes hashtag Wacom
right now it is kind of the the graphics
standard for professionals to use a
Wacom brand-new tablet just want to put
that out there yeah yeah and Bentley if
you're paying attention even though
Mart's and I don't have one we would
like to have one yeah for sure right and
if you can only send one send it my way
first and then mark when you visit the
US you can try for as much as you want
that's fine we can train my logo for
that for one car whenever you amazing
that won't be sick yeah yeah now I have
to tell you guys his story there's the
guy his name is extra maize and he runs
the logo critique group for me inside
Facebook so you guys want in on that go
look him up and answer the questions
he'll add you to that group but he just
shared with me recently and he's living
out of the Middle East right now and he
shared with me that he just sold a logo
for ten thousand dollars and I was like
wow that's so cool
and it was a local he already made even
better he posted something on be hands
and it was like a logo for America it's
really interesting with the United
States flag and somebody saw it yeah
they had a couple of conversations and
he sold it and I was like so proud of
him
amazing so those people who continuously
drop comments like oh you in real world
they love to say it like this I'm gonna
use their voice in my mind well in the
real world you only get five hundred
bucks for fifty bucks tops that's it
maximum this is this guy's high on glue
that doesn't make any sense super famous
yeah super eighty it's well okay you're
right you're absolutely right I agree
with you the most you
never get is $50 you marked myself and
Zach will get something different just
throwing it out there all right now I'm
gonna get some extra hate on that one
well doing logos for like $50 but start
somewhere right that's right but did you
do that before after you've watched the
feature well I'll be honest like your
videos on the design of how the price
logo design for example really helped me
to change my mindset in that so great
and then actually off of death I posted
in I think it was the Facebook group
designers make and then you contacted me
to do this there are no guitar review
sessions so much like it for me ii was
fully know how do you say it complete
yeah it's like the what is he the baboon
in in the Lion King he holds it up like
Simba we need some majestic music right
now yeah some drums play some desk rooms
here we needed a live musician on the
show that's what we need very cool right
yeah it's gonna do splash here so long
apparently Bentley is owned by
Volkswagen their subsidiary now we still
can't think positive man it's still good
actually volkswagen the volkswagen group
owns a lot of companies also own Porsche
they own Lamborghini no they don't
today yeah and they own Audi wasn't
common specs we've ordered to drive yes
yes they were so a lot of the companies
that manufactured the war machines after
World War two were dismantled and they
went into something else so they made
motorcycles and airplanes and all kinds
of different things and cars
mark mark are there any interesting
comments or questions or things that we
need to address let me scan here Lud
just comments on what you were talking
about with Rafiki from from Lion King
yes let's see if I had the talent to
sing and carry a tune I would just do it
but as soon as I do that we're gonna
lose a thousand subscribers so we're not
gonna go there yeah no questions if you
guys have questions about what Mart's
designing here let us know in the chat
mm-hmm so there was a question I saw
this
they're asking Mart do you use the Wacom
tablet when you're an illustrator that's
a great question no mostly use it for
sketching in Photoshop right then once I
go into illustrator I think my workflow
just works better with my mouse same
here so great minds think alike they're
use the tool for the job
I know some people use a Wacom tablet
and stylus for everything I find out
when I'm trying to draw really precise
curves it just doesn't flow as well I
also for something with a pen tool like
it just feels a bit weird been trying to
make a curve with the pencil hmm if
someone was asking how do we select the
designers for the show so yeah they're
go ahead you wanna Chris you want to ask
her the first way you were doing yeah
hold hold onto that mark was gonna say
sometime aren't ya video so the video is
finished now
this is like the old design okay okay
let's zoom in on this okay so the the
original design had a lot more detail
and the curve of the wing you could see
that there's a little dip there it has a
little concave there and it spreads out
and there's a lot more detail on the
inner part of the wing
so that's to me a little bit more true
to like a real bird's wing but not that
I've studied them okay so on the right
here we have the the plumage from the
tail feathers part of me we have the
plumage from the tail feathers there the
wing expands and it's a little bit more
of a triangular shape but I think in
cutting out parts of the wing it still
feels it's it doesn't feel as heavy as a
triangular shape would be so I think
that was a really smart decision to add
some of that black space at the bottom
of the be there at the left and right of
the B all right so can we zoom in real
tight on this is this live in
Illustrator now or something now this is
just some NACA - stuff like that
okay so like all right so this is some
variation because I think the first on
the left isn't really suitable for
everything so I just wanted to create a
version where it's like just simply to
be above it and on the left of it
mr. construction of how I create the
logo people always really seem to like
this show I see how this is the
thumbnail so send us this for the
thumbnail okay okay yeah keep on yeah so
so far eh don't black and white yeah and
then always the Makos which also people
really seem to like yeah this is this is
one of my favorite mock-ups I don't know
for some reason when you put a logo on
fat break it just looks so different
feels alive yeah so this one might be
for example under the window of a car
dealership or something like that maybe
now before you wait before you go on any
further did you build an actual emblem
for the hood ornament
well I even thought about the content
one of my friends was like 3d design
yeah it wasn't it wasn't available so
that was a shame you know what that's
not a friend to me then
logo redesign then you're done okay well
I would have thought that would have
been really cool yeah hmm so that was it
all right very nice very good let me
give you well done all right so let's
pull up a and B let's let's look at the
other side by side so we'll have our
audience vote I'm getting nervous you
were very confident before okay I was
nervous for tomorrow I'm not gonna lie
it's B months right yes I think I just
finally remembered how to say your name
at the end of the show I was like all
choked up on this okay all right so a is
on the left side that's the original
logo everybody with its rich heritage
and B is marts version feels more modern
and in his critique of the original
which I'm not sure I agree with but he
said it felt like clipart and he
streamlined it made it more minimal and
steered it away from you the Third Reich
but I think he was able to find a
balance there so let us know in the chat
do you prefer a the original or B the
new and improved version form art let us
know and if specially if you're a
motorist motoring enthusiast person who
loves cars we'd really love to hear from
you because I think ultimately that's
that's who who matters right people are
really into cars and especially if
you're in the high-end luxury automobile
Bentley welcome if you're paying
attention you know what to do with us
okay all right looks like he's all over
ya you scatter days couple here and
there couple we won't call them haters
but I think we also have to take into
consideration the emotional attachment
that we have to things and sometimes
you're messing around with people's
childhood like for example if if a mom
or dad took their kid out for a drive on
an open road and a British road
somewhere you know and they had that
megaphone would've been able to to show
this like I'm an extra car would then it
would have been even more life than I
guess now would have been it if it was a
really a hood ornament
then we would know or you know what if
you took actually this is really
important I want to take a moment to
talk about this if you actually went on
the Bentley site it pulled some of their
product photography meaning cars and
people using lifestyle shots and you
swapped out or covered their logo that
would really give us a true test so all
the new designers out there when you're
designing a logo make sure you put it in
context with the existing brand and
you'll know right away
does the logo fit and if it doesn't you
must have quit I'm just kidding then you
gotta get rid of it all right the racer
failure is such a strong word this is
called your first attempt in learning
this right ok very good let's see here
people are gonna some sec still looks a
little not seen I don't know I don't
know you guys maybe maybe not
okay so mark what is the question let's
answer some questions now yep yeah
earlier people are asking how do we
select the designers for the show right
okay initially the way that we selected
designers on the show was I saw people
who were engaging in the groups or
commenting on things that I was doing
and I saw their work and it was really
really good and that's it so everybody
that's been on logotherapy so far has
been personally selected and invited by
me by invitation only but what we're
starting to realize is there are more
people who want to do logotherapy logo
redesign with us and so we want to open
it up a little bit so we're gonna try an
experiment so this is the first time we
held an open casting call edition if you
will for people who I think are talented
who are good on camera because these
things are kind of important we're good
on camera and we'll give them a shot and
we'll see how it goes right
I like to bring on people who I know are
gonna do a really good job so that we're
supporting best practices and we're
reinforcing really good design yeah it's
good for everybody I think we try to
create a win-win situation here
especially when money starts rolling
into these episodes not from you guys
but from sponsors I think that would be
amazing like Adobe Wacom all the big
players should be supporting this kind
of stuff because we're using the tools
in creative ways to make good design now
the thing I wanted to say really quickly
was I've been looking on internet on
these kind of logo redesign things and
we're seeing a bunch of people design
logos and that's really cool and they're
getting a lot of attention fantastic for
them but the kinds of design decisions
they're making I cringe at not because I
like the aesthetic or not but the just I
can tell it's not built on a really
solid foundation of understanding design
principles but to each their own I don't
want to sit here and tell you like I
should be the judge for all things good
but that's why we want to counter some
of the things that are may be doing a
disservice to the design community by
perpetuating bad practices with really
healthy solid foundations and design by
professionals just like Mart ok no
casting couch Marco we don't do that
that's a you talk about a different
Hollywood mobile casting couch it's
merit only we live in a meritocracy okay
people shows the work we decide we don't
know who you are and we say yes or no ok
what's the next question mark we've got
a good one from another fellow logo
designer here Everton but he's asking
Mart FX howdy yeah how do you approach
the integrity of the logo that has more
than one element so in this case letter
B and the wings and I think we saw the
little bit but I think he needs a little
bit more explanation great so and I
think the most important part of this
logo for me was to be but there's really
reason is a little bit but not nothing
drastic and the wings I just went crazy
on so that's it this is just personal
preference of course when you're working
actually working for Bentley they will
probably also tell you from how much
limitations you will have in terms of
designing the redesigning the wings or
whatever or in this case if this was
basically just my take on their logo and
I guess it's also a bit of a personal
taste info because personally really
like minimalistic and sophistic know
girls so that's why
my redesign but when you're actually
working for clients and of course as all
the flexor stuff that you have to keep
in mind I don't know if it that answers
the question though it's I don't know
that's my answer
okay something else I want to say when
you guys are looking to redesign a logo
that's famous here's what I would
probably suggest that you do before you
design anything go on social media find
out as much as you can about how people
react to the current logo look at all
the different applications that it has
to be used on and I think this is where
designers need to make sure form a
function is over form okay because just
because you don't like the aesthetic
that's one thing but you have to look at
how it's being used and the most
practical application is to take that
into consideration a while back we did
an episode on the new f1 logo and people
are losing their mind they're just
freaking out like oh my god this is
horrible and then what you realize is
you look at f1 cars and they're really
long and skinny everything is long and
skinny on an f1 car Formula One and so
then when they see this logo in context
there it makes a lot more sense
sometimes the application will inform
the design decisions that you're making
if you're designing a logo that's meant
to mostly be seen on a tall narrow
building you're gonna have to design a
logo that's very vertical and there's
issues there too so solving that kind of
problem I think that's what it has to
happen so I look at this and I think the
true test to this would be how does this
look as a three-dimensional metallic
emblem that sits on the hood that's how
we can tell if the spacing is too thin
or it's too thick and we make
adjustments so in the real world I think
what would happen is is marked being
paid hundreds of thousands of dollars to
design this logo would have 3d
fabricator build some of this stuff and
then he would look at he to make
decisions and this process would take up
something like this yeah Oh what
happened here this is actually a mock-up
I found but it didn't really look like
Carl and so yeah yeah that's pretty good
but I was talking about like you know in
the hood it's curved there's different
dimensions
things are raised and this sculpting
happening here right and we've done this
before too when we were gonna yeah
someone needs help out here
so somebody who knows some 3d modeling
turn this into something more
dimensional looking add some curvature
to it because hood ornaments are not
straight it live on a curved surface
okay
mark do we have other questions yeah I
got another question about your
selection process you had a lot of
different explorations how did you like
your final one where is the Hoth
question well first of all the the
reasoning of it looking a bit like the
Second World War
like an eagle style in the beginning and
also I mean this like the easy answer to
get but it's it's true in this case it's
a bit of intuition like when you're
doing something a lot and after a while
you will start recognizing like the good
decisions on the bad decisions so I know
it's easy to get as an answer but in my
case when I usually have like great like
50 different sketches for clients but I
will know which one will most likely be
the one that declined chooses so I don't
know if that's it's the isn't it it's an
answer they will appreciate but that's
that's how it is for me that makes sense
and then to follow up on that
see you word really doing this for
Bentley would you present more than one
or do you just select that final one
mm-hmm it's also a good question well I
probably would have created more
sketched in what I've one of them what
I've done now so I probably would also
would have had a couple more options
which I really liked
I don't know Souths question and also
been depends a bit on what you negotiate
the front like how much they want to see
and how much they are willing to pay for
it I think two or three proposals
usually it's pretty normal but also one
could also work Christy have any
feedback on that just from your
experiences - yeah I do
when I was younger
and when I'm in my 20s many years ago
many many years ago I would come in and
do super tight vector drawings of all
the different ideas that I had because I
wasn't I'm not as good of a sketcher in
as martes and so I just used illustrator
and I would make a bunch of things and
I'd get rid of the ones that I don't
like but I would sometimes will
literally walk into a client meeting and
have sixteen logos and we we figured out
a way to present them that the clients
just just adored and I'll just give you
guys a little tip here what we did was
we printed them out high quality like
super crisp like laser printer and then
we would mount them on foam core and cut
them out in I think four inch by four
inch squares so each logo existed like a
white tile like a like a tile that you
use in a bathroom right there's
dimension to it and we would lay them
out in a neat grid on the pic on the
table and then we would say okay here's
what we've done we love most of them
there's a summer that we think you
wanted to see so we've included those we
won't tell you which is which and then
you pick and then what they would do is
I get so hard to pick Chris there's too
many here and so what's really cool
about doing it this modular way is they
could take the ones they don't like and
move them off to the side and through a
process of elimination like oh I like
this one by don't so they would just
arrange it and so there's this very
tactile quality if they can touch things
and move them around which is really
cool and so they would say oh I like
this one and then you could see the
different decision makers sometimes
there's two or three people in the room
and they're not but I like this one I'd
say what each person needs to pick their
favorite and you get to see how they
work so it becomes a game and eventually
they reduced it down to two or three we
have a discussion about it and then we
reduce it down to one and then sit turn
that tile over maybe turn it over and if
it had my signature on it that's the one
I picked - what they don't realize is I
put my signature in all of them
I'm just kidding about that it's like
David Blaine Street magic all right so
that's what they were doing like we like
this one okay now let's talk about what
we need to do to get this to be perfect
and get everybody signed off on this
because I noticed there was some debate
okay very cool so
we would talk about it and then I would
go back into the studio and work on it
some more and then eventually we get to
the place where Marta's is here's the
final logo back then we didn't do
mock-ups and other stuff we didn't have
all these ideas on how to present logos
we just presented the logo all right how
would I do differently today because I
did preface it that in my youth that's
what I used to do I would present lots
of ideas I didn't know what was right or
wrong in terms of like what was right
for the company I knew that the forum
that it took aesthetically was right but
now totally different approach now I'm
in my forties almost hitting 50 all
right now in my 40s I would try to just
present one logo and the process is
dramatically different what we would do
is have a conversation with the client
get into discovery and find out what
we're trying to do with the logo or the
brand should achieve and form an idea
about who the end customer is what what
their life looks like their pain points
and their challenges and we would build
very complex mood boards we call them
style escapes right or empathy maps and
we would say like okay the ideal
customer of yours looks like this speaks
like this dresses like this and lives in
this world they're active they're eating
these kinds of things these are the
kinds of colors that they live in and we
get alignment and agreement on that so
what we want to do is be able to find a
logo that fits neatly into this world of
their ideal customer look when I was
talking tomorrow earlier about Bentley
you want to take images from the Bentley
brand on their website that speaks to
who they are and the lifestyle and just
put in the new logo and if it fits it
feels right that's with an existing
company but oftentimes with the clients
that we work with they're either wanting
to grow their market to a different
customer or the rebranding or their
brand new startup so this is really
helpful to create this empathy map with
images of who their customers are and
through that we start to define the tone
of voice how they want to sound to the
world and the look in the field we want
to be bold we want to be confident we
want to be fast we want to be
streamlined we want to suggest
solidarity or whatever that we've
you have a 200 year history okay so
maybe it's nostalgic we work through
these in words and ideas first and we
get alignment and we get people to sign
off on that and then when we go away
we'll do one last step before we design
the logo will go away say okay based on
the criteria that you described we're
going to show you a bunch of logos that
to us feel like what you said we just
want to make sure because one person's
nostalgia is somebody else's nostalgia
right we show them that and they are yes
this is it so it's almost like we're pre
designing the logo beforehand so if
Bentley in their desire to rebrand
they're like we want to get rid of the
wings and and Mart actually didn't have
a conversation with them pretty much
every exploration he did would be now
moot and he'd go back to the drawing
board and he would feel like you mother
you know I'm all right yeah I know so
that's why it's really important to have
these conversations to be to expand what
it can be and then to reduce it my
design professor would call i like this
double funnel system where it opens up
at the beginning it narrows down and
then opens up one more time for
exploration and then it narrows down and
then you're done so at that point we
present one logo and instead of saying
oh my god that's incredible their
expressions should be Christo of course
you did exactly what we'd hope you do
based on all the conversations so you're
looking to get perpetual alignment with
the client before you do the work and
this is really really important and if
you guys want to know more about this
process it seems like it's a scripted
like how did he say all this it's
because this is part of our logo design
process it's in our logo design course
right mark yes it is yes yeah and Mark
wanted me to remind you guys that during
this this global pandemic that we're all
suffering through and that all of our
courses are 20% off I think something
like that yeah okay so other thoughts
other questions mark or Mart
what do you think anything else before
we get out of here question for me I
mean or I don't know questions for him
or I don't have any questions myself
what you saying you do not have our logo
course no I'm sorry this is a travesty
we're gonna send you a code for it okay
yeah yeah and then you can make fun of
us if you like okay use elements from
your little course let's do it
yes I would love to send it to you so a
Jonah follow up with with marts and sent
him the logo course okay mark in any any
last questions yeah you just answered
like three questions when you were just
talking about everything so I think I
think we're good no other major pressing
ones that could even be a promo for it
[Laughter]
yeah is everyone invited to the toxin
mark oh I like that
let's do that you know maybe do it in a
way where someone that is washing or
some one of you guys is selecting a logo
and then I'm just going to go blank into
it and I like that that's that way
there's no way you can prepare in
advance right yeah that's a bold move my
friend I like that okay so there we go
the next logo therapy or logo redesign
with Mart Dumont's is going to have you
submit a logo and then we'll vote on it
and then he'll get going and we'll see
how he does it so he'll just make one
logo at this point okay so some final
comments here on the logo itself some
things I like and some things I want to
be critical of okay so you ready Mart
yeah I'm ready okay the one thing I
really miss about the original logo is
that the wings overlap a little bit so
it feels dimensional even though it's 2d
I also like that the tail feathers of
the bird are kind of contained within
the circle for some reason it feels like
as this thing is coming towards me as a
as a hood ornament it feels a little
sleeker and faster okay that's it now in
terms of like your logo I think it's you
made a lot of really smart decisions and
those of you guys who have had to draw
wings before
it's a lot more difficult than the mark
made it look for sure because every time
I try and draw wings something doesn't
feel right the proportion something is
off
I like how streamline your logo is and I
like how geometric it is it's very
angular but it still has some rounded
corners that actually make it look
pleasing tonight it doesn't feel sharp
and what I mean by that is sometimes you
can draw really super angular sharp
logos and visually feels like it can cut
you and so I think you you made smart
decisions and rounding off some areas
there the bottom of the feathers very
nice okay once again
good job Mart you go and next time we
see you you're gonna have you're gonna
be a little bit smarter because you take
in our amazing logo thing logo design
course but you gotta leave the mobile
times live yeah live how cool would that
be you guys so make sure you tune in for
that and until next time everybody we'll
see you later I'm supposed to do some
graphics here which I'm not ready for
okay you wanna check out more mark here
he is okay and then guys don't forget to
to like comment and subscribe
thank you for being part of our 1
billion mission to teach and empower
creative people to to earn a living
doing what they love that's it for us we
will see you guys next time bye bye